for those people stuck on the highway
there oh lots of patients yeah lots of
patients we were just talking about how
many people are stranded here in las
vegas but you're right like i mean look
at the weather right now yeah crazy not
a bad place to be stranded not a bad
place to be stranded at all and we have
fantastic sunsets oh people went crazy
over last night emailed our email
with all of your pictures and videos and
thank you for that here's one of them
okay i got so many to choose from uh
take a look at this one monday sunset
from corey sadler i love this shot
because not only do we have the sunset
but i'm gonna go hit his pool
yeah not any time soon he's got it
running though
for a reason because a lot of you had
your pools running because we had those
cold freezing temperatures overnight
mine consistently stayed on just because
it was below freezing in my neighborhood
that's a great shot there we could get
that again tonight just depending on how
much cloud cover we get we're not going
to have as much clouds as yesterday so
probably won't be as nice 53 centenni
hills right now in sky canyon 55 for you
sandy or and spring valley 55 north las
vegas so we're out of the 40s now so
this is a little bit better right
whitney ranch 57 54 mountains to edge
and roads ranch 52 anthem 52 henderson
still still a little chilly but not
quite as cold as you've been seeing for
daytime highs lately 51 indian springs
right now probably at 55 up to northeast
clark mesquite thanks for watching us 51
degrees at this hour so a lot of clouds
another storm impacting the west coast
seattle has had a total of nine inches
of snow they've had more snow in seattle
than denver colorado what's going on
right more rain continues in portland
oregon all the way to northern
california but as we zoom into us
all we're going to get is some high
cloud cover really thickest to the north
of us but not anticipating any of that
rain here unfortunately in fact our rain
chances seem pretty slim even as we have
an approaching storm another system that
will impact the west coast again later
on the work week we just not enough low
level moisture here and again the sierra
is going to swallow up all that rain so
we would just have no chances big
chances for rain here however we've been
talking about that snowstorm that hit
the east coast well they got to brace
themselves for another storm look at
this thursday look at all that snow
mid-atlantic again all the way up to the
northeast so as they're digging out of
that snow that coastal low is going to
give them more snow thursday and friday
and strong winds along with that now i
really love living in las vegas i really
do 38 degrees overnight clear and chilly
christian and i we had to cover those
snowstorms of the east coast they were
not fun normal temperatures below normal
for overnight low 59 degrees for
tomorrow milder though and mostly sunny
so we're getting closer to 60 degrees in
fact i've got some 60s
on our 8 day forecast here look at that
even 63 on friday what what
your weekend
sunny skies still next week high 50s
even
and cooler but still
staying dry that is your most accurate
forecast kirsten kristen over here looks
beautiful